- Hey, guys.
Two days ago, the VaynerMedia interns came
and spent a half an hour with me.
It ended up being about 40
minutes or I don't know,
actually, we'll see
officially in the time below.
But it was, it really just
clicked, and kinda Alex,
Gabe and I, just kinda
looked at each other,
and were like, let's put this out,
and let's put it out ASAP.
So, if you're ending your internship,
or you have somebody doing an internship,
or for next year's internship,
or just in general,
if you're navigating life in
the early stages of the dawn
of your career, watch this video.
And I made a video that went pretty viral
a couple years ago,
like, I couldn't believe more, in like,
the people aspect of all of this.
There's nothing you learn from
anybody, I don't give a fuck
how hands on, or how much
you've actually done,
none of it is even remotely close to as,
or are why positive as, as
like, the people you meet.
Especially, you know,
I don't know how young,
or where you guys are,
but like, if some of you come back
and intern again next year or
work here or somewhere else,
if you're lucky enough
to get into a place like a VaynerMedia,
there's many, I mean, we
have our unique cultures,
and I think, things that
are very much an anomaly,
but let's just talk
about a growing company
that's going to be an industry leader.
Like, it's crazy to me that
some of the people you're
working for right now,
are literally going to be the CMOs
of the biggest companies of the world.
Like, people just don't understand
how life actually works,
and like, how actually this all plays out,
hey, this actually plays out, is ...
It's going to only be about the people.
Like, the skills or commoditized.
There's a lot of people
that are going to be
able to do what you do,
but like, who you meet,
and how they play out,
and like, more importantly,
because of the uniqueness of our company,
who the people that you're
working with become,
like, do you ever see those
crazy, like documentaries,
where like, Spielberg and Lucas,
and like, fuckin', you
know, all those guys
like hung out together, right?
Or like, what I grew up
in in Silicon Valley,
like, I would have dinner
and be like Zuckerberg,
and Travis from Uber,
like there's moments in time,
and in advertising or communication,
if that's what you give a shit about,
that moment in time is
VaynerMedia people, here now.
Lots of these people will go on
and be the CEOs of agencies or brands,
or things of that nature,
and I could, you know what,
it might be tough at a young age.
You, it might, it's tough at an older age,
like, you may not be extroverted,
it might feel weird to say hello,
but like, in your last week,
or what have you, like,
as much cafeteria time,
as much like, "Hello,"
as much as you can like, muster
up, literally, "Hi, um..."
I believe in it the most.
The "Hi, um..." in the elevator.
Like, first of all, we
have a good culture,
like, it's less scary to say
hello to somebody cold here,
than other places.
I don't think we're
perfect, and I, you know,
but like, to me, I'd wanna
legitimately fire anybody
who's not gonna be nice,
unless they're dealing
with a real tough issue
in their life at that moment,
where they won't at least say, "Hey."
They may be busy or might be shy,
or, you know, might not love
to be interpersonal, fine,
but it's less scary here to say hello cold
in the cafeteria, or you know,
walking up the stairs in
production, or whatever,
and so, couldn't push you more.
If you get anything out of this,
like that one random hello
that this musters out,
could literally be the
whole fuckin' thing.
Just could, just is.
Actually, I think that's my
advice, and we talked about this
a little bit in the VaynerSports stuff,
like, that's my advice for
when you go back to school.
Like, probably my favorite talk,
I've given the last couple years
was to the USC Football
team, for many reasons,
one, Sam Darnold, went on to
become the Jet's quarterback,
and so, we became friends because of that,
so that's awesome,
but way more, was, you
know, I speak a lot,
I do this a lot,
and you can always tell
when you hit a nerve.
There's a moment in that USC Football talk
where I tell them, I'm like,
"You guys are fuckin' idiots,
you think you're so cool
"'cause you're on the USC Football team,
"meanwhile, 99% of you, this
is the highlight of your life.
"99% of you, this is the apex, this is it.
"Everything after not making the NFL,
"is gonna be downhill,
"and you're walking into
these fucking classrooms,
"and 60% of those kids are
gonna go on to do real shit,
"and you think you're too fuckin' cool,
"and putting your Beats by Dre
on, and your fuckin' hoodie
"and not looking anybody in the eye,
"and think you're somebody, and
your life is gonna suck shit
"for the next 50 years,
'cause you didn't say hello
"to the kid sitting next to you
"who went on to fuckin' run Disney."
That is the best piece
of advice I can give you.
Like, when you go back to school,
like, say hello to everybody.
People are the ROI of life.
So, it's cool that you got,
like, better at analytics,
or like real life experience
of talking to a client,
commodity, you would've
gotten at some point, anyway.
Whether you can do it or not, cool,
but like, actually becoming friends
with each other in here, like actually.
Not like when the Slack Channel dies.
Like, everybody in here
can help the other person, potentially,
in a real significant way, you know?
80% of you, especially if you
don't get into this company,
are gonna have jobs you fuckin'
hate right outta school,
and the other person's gonna
have something they like,
and they can be the one
recommending you in.
People.
Questions?
You can go anywhere, by the way,
like, very specific to your own shit,
like, please go anywhere.
- You talk a lot about being self aware
and playing on your strengths.
So then, for you personally,
when you don't have a gut
instinct for a decision,
how do you reach that moment of clarity?
- That's a great question.
One, that doesn't happen very often,
and I'll tell you why.
It's the same reason, if you look at,
I don't know how much you guys
have consumed of me or not,
all my bravado, me cutting people off,
like, all the things I
do, they're very obvious.
It's 'cause I only stay in
the lane of what I know.
Like, you would die, like
when my wife and I meet,
like a new school couple,
and we go out to dinner,
and like, I'm trying to
be a cordial dinner guest,
and I'm trying to meet people,
and they start talking
about a subject matter,
you'd laugh on how quiet I can get.
I'm not interested in talking
about shit I don't know.
It, things are very clear to me.
Like, making a decision about my business,
this is what I fuckin' do, right?
So, it's not like, I'm
always in clarity mode.
If I don't know, I go through a process.
Like, if, you know, if
Emily is having a huge,
you know, argument with Brian Suh,
and I need to figure it out,
and I don't have a feel,
'cause a lot of times I do,
50, 60%, I already have my
assumptions and knowledge
'cause I'm interacting
with people at scale.
I'll just go through the process.
Right, I'll meet with other people, like,
but like, making decisions
comes very natural to me.
Mainly 'cause I'm not scared of loss.
The biggest vulnerability
everybody has here
is their worried about
somebody else's judgment.
The reason there's no moment of clarity
is you don't wanna jump.
You don't wanna jump because
you're worried if you lose
what people are gonna say,
starting with your parents,
your friends, your contemporaries.
My ability to not truly, truly
care about other people's opinions,
has been the foundation of my happiness.
I respect people's opinions.
I just, I just don't care
about their judgment of me.
I flip flopped about project
management of VaynerMedia,
like, so many times,
and I don't worry if somebody here's like,
"Make a decision,"
or like, "You're stupid,"
or, like, "What the fuck?"
or, "Why are we always changing?"
Like, go work at Great Advertising.
Got it?
- Yeah, thank you.
- You're welcome.
- So, there's a certain level
that you obviously see yourself getting to
in terms of success.
- Yes.
- And anybody, going on that
path, finds a lot of obstacles
in its way, and we hear all of you,
we hear all of the things that you say
on your content and all
the advice that you give,
but on a personal level,
have you ever gotten to
an obstacle or challenge
that you genuinely thought
would be insurmountable?
- No.
- You just said like, I don't know
I don't know where to go from this point.
- No, because I think the subtlety
that people struggle with is,
I don't care about buying the jets,
I care about trying to buy the jets.
I'm in love with the process.
My ROI is the process.
So, the insurmountable
thing, is the best part.
You know?
There's also nothing insurmountable
when you really live a life of like,
as long as nine people don't die or get,
you know, diagnosed with
terminal death, like, sentences,
everything else is really fuckin' simple.
I, you know, I couldn't commun--
You know, I have a lot of
empathy for this cynicism,
like some of you may know
this, though, most of you
haven't had the luxury
of getting close to me,
but like, some that are
starting to get close to me,
who have been very close to me,
nobody believes that
what they see on video
is who I actually am.
I mean, just,
but that doesn't bother me.
Like, like, that will
eventually be exposed or not.
Like, people get close to me
that I don't have control
over their opinion.
I mean, Caleb's gonna
really, really know me soon,
or already, really, really does
as somebody who consumed
a lot of my content,
and the delta's extraordinary.
I guess where I'm going with that is
nothing is insurmountable,
this is just life.
Like, my fear, my kryptonite, is ...
Like, the big one, is
my wife driving my kids
and getting hit by a Mack
truck, and they're dead.
Like, that's like, fuck!
Like, that's like, am
I in a one-year cloud?
Am I in a forever cloud?
Like, I don't have a sense yet
what happens with my great
first true tragedy, right?
For a long time I'd fear the
shit out of my parents dying.
I am over that hump.
Maybe I just got enough time, to be frank.
You know, maybe I'm just
so grateful to be 42,
and have like, I'm pretty in a good spot.
Like, I'm just in that place.
I mean, I used to really cry about it.
Now, that's been transposed
to my wife and kids, right,
but even that, I'll be
honest with you, man,
to be very frank,
I don't know how not to
default into gratitude.
I default into, like,
"What if Lizzie and I
weren't able to have kids,
and I never would've even had that time?"
It goes into a very like, my wiring,
and then, my practicing of my wiring,
is just like, the inability to dwell.
I don't think anybody has control over me.
I never worry about my family.
I never worry about the
government, the President,
any of it, I don't dwell.
I just think I'm in control.
So, how do you feel,
how does something feel insurmountable
when you know, when you
know, you're in control?
I didn't even say "thought,"
like, notice, like that
was even interesting to me,
when you know you're in control.
Like, what are you complaining about?
Fix it.
You don't like the school you're going to,
and your parents made you go there?
Quit.
Don't go, what's gonna happen?
You're not gonna talk to
your parents for two years?
Cool, like you'll, then talk to them.
Like, my biggest thing
right now with youth is
do what you want
because if you're appeasing your parents,
you're gonna resent them,
and be regretful your whole life,
and then, you're not gonna actually have
a relationship with your parents.
I look at, I spend all my
time looking at old people.
Not young people.
Old people have played,
and when old people hate their old parents
because they did what
their parents wanted,
I'm like, "That's wrong, fuck it.
"Have the problems now with your parents,
"for 24, and 36, 48 months,
"and then, here's the good
news, then it's merit."
If you were right, that
you're actually a rapper,
not a lawyer, if you
became a successful rapper,
they're gonna be proud as fuck.
If you don't, well then, guess what,
they were right, at least
that you weren't a rapper,
maybe you're still not a lawyer,
but the merit of the game will play out.
Too many people, in their youth want both,
they wanna claim that their
parents are full of shit,
or this is wrong,
but they don't wanna take the
jump into what they claim,
and so, you want both.
You wanna shit on the establishment,
but you're not willing to take the risk
to prove if you're good enough,
then you're full of shit, not them.
- Thank you.
- Yeah, but it's super easy
out here once it gets quiet, brother.
Once you can't hear anything,
it gets super easy out here.
- What's the number one piece of advice
you wish you would've
known when you were our age
or something that you would
have done differently?
- I probably could've
enjoyed my 20s a little more.
Like, I don't think you guys understand
how real my propaganda of my youth is.
I did nothing but worked.
Like all of you, all of you
had more fun this weekend,
than I had between 18
and 29, that's weird.
So I think I went too far
the other way, you know,
Like, an Ibiza or Coachella
would've probably been good for me.
(laughter)
None of that exists for me, you know?
And I think, I don't regret
it because it's my truth,
but in hindsight, like nothing is good
when it's out of balance,
and like, I was 107, like, I
literally lost all my friends.
Like, not out of like,
loss, 'cause I'm a good guy,
and they're good and it was nice,
but like, there was no modern technology,
there was no smart phone,
and so, like, I just fuckin' checked out,
and just worked in a
liquor store for a decade
without putting up my head.
- Don't you think that helped
get to where you are now?
- 100%.
- And do you think that if
you had spent, you know,
the weekend going to Coachella--
- Well, to answer her
question, I used to think that,
but now in hindsight, I do
think one fuckin' weekend,
or even one week in the summer,
probably in hindsight, wouldn't
have changed the outcome,
but at the time, I didn't think that,
and so, if I would do something different,
I would've taken one trip,
but I'm talkin' one trip.
Like, I worked, you know,
retail's weird, I worked weekends.
Like, everyone's here like,
"Oh, what a tough week."
I'm like, "What if you had
to work all day Saturday,
"and that was the most intense day,"
'cause that's what it was in retail.
That was the day, right?
And Sunday, and because I
worked like 7:00am to 11:00pm,
Sunday, was like sleep in.
Like, I literally woke
up at like 10:30, 11, 12,
and like, hung out with AJ,
'cause you know, like ...
Like, even like, you know,
one of the things I regret is,
in essence, how I treated the two girls
I dated the most during that time
because it was just literally,
like, checking the box
to have companionship,
'cause it was just like
100% business, you know?
So, but at the same token,
the reason I don't talk a lot about that
is I think everybody else,
all of you for example, all of you
are way too far in the other delta,
if you have substantial ambitions.
If you don't, that's cool.
Like, my whole thing, always, is like
if you wanna make 100,000 a year,
have great work/life balance, like cool,
but like, too many kids
are talking right now
about billionaire and millionaire
and crushing it and dominating,
and just nowhere close to
putting in the pieces of
training themselves for what
it's gonna take, you know?
I don't think people understand
what a 1% life means.
It means 1% actions to your point.
You have to sacrifice a lot,
and by the way, I don't
think that's right.
I think it's right for me
'cause it was my calling,
it was in my head every minute.
You have to be self-aware,
but I think part of self-awareness
is not to talk shit,
you know, about what you're gonna do
because then, you're putting yourself in a
you've got to back up your actions.
One of the biggest reasons I
want kids to talk less shit,
is 'cause their putting
themselves into a fuckin' trap.
You're talking a big
game, everybody heard it.
Now, you feel the social
pressure to deliver on it,
but you don't have the fuckin'
chops, or the willingness,
or appetite to do it,
which I think, then, just needs one great,
you know, blog post or video, or you know,
piece of content that
makes you admit that.
I don't think you're in a trap,
you just have to acknowledge it.
- [Intern] So we met AJ last week--
- Nice, AJ did this?
- [Interns] Yeah.
- For the whole group?
That's awesome!
(laughter)
That makes me happy.
Was he talking like old war stories?
(laughter)
- [Intern] You guys
have an 11-year age gap.
- Yes.
- [Intern] Me and my brother
have an 11-year age gap.
I was wondering, he was
kind of mentioning you
and your working relationship,
and how it's been really good
because of your age gap.
I was wondering what's something
you've learned from him
throughout this whole process?
- A lot, actually.
So, I actually would disagree with AJ.
I don't think our age gap was the driver,
I think empathy, and compassion,
and true love over money is.
Really.
That being said, it probably didn't hurt
because it probably allowed him,
even though, he's competitive and alpha,
to maybe concede certain things to me
'cause of how far along I was
and where I really always played
the 1A to his 1B, for real,
unlike, the friction my dad and I had
where we both tried to be
two cooks in a kitchen.
So, I've played both, I
know what it looks like
to have consensus of partners and not.
So, I've got a lot of context for it.
AJ taught me a lot, actually,
and which, so, I think
I've evolved quite a bit
in being more, having more radical candor
and shooting it straight.
I'm so positive
that I don't like
confrontation and negativity,
which I think led to me
handling a lot of things wrong in my youth
where I wasn't, I would try to like,
I feel like if I, you
know the cliché thing,
like the girl trying to
turn around the bad boy,
and that's like the kind of boy she likes?
I feel like I have that gear too.
I feel like I'm always on a charity case,
or like, if somebody's not good enough,
like, I'm gonna help them,
or, if they work at Vayner,
they'll be happier and more successful,
and I have broad enough shoulders
to create that environment.
'Cause they won't be successful
out there without me,
and I think I misplayed that,
and I think AJ is a very straight shooter,
and watching him manage that
closely, it rubbed off on me.
I think AJ also, back
to the earlier question
is dramatically more
into smelling the roses
and enjoying success,
and having some sort of work/life balance,
you know, and I think that
rubbed off on me, as well,
a little bit during our time together.
You know, another thing
that stands out is,
that really worked,
and it's probably why I
wish you guys could feel
the way I feel towards you.
I was such a wiz kid, that
I respected AJ from day one.
Like, just 'cause he was
straight outta school,
I thought his opinion
carried as much weight,
and so, it wasn't necessarily
what he taught me,
it was being together, it
taught me that that's right,
and like, like, we accept in sports
that you can be LeBron and Kobe,
but we don't in business.
One of the reason your
internship is allowing you
some freedom to do shit, and
I know some of you didn't,
like, I know there's a delta,
some of you did a ton of ton of shit,
you know, I can't control
900 people every second,
but why there's a culture
more here of like,
compared to some of your
friends who are like,
"Really, you're doing shit?
"Like, I'm fuckin', like
just sitting here, like,
"fuckin' playing on fuckin',"
who the fuck, anyway,
(laughter)
is because of that respect
for, maybe you're good enough
to run my company right now.
Like, talent is talent.
And so, but candor,
smelling roses, stand out.
- [Intern] Since you're constantly filming
and releasing new content,
and it's always so positive and inspiring,
does anything ever happen
in your home or work life
that, like, puts you in a funk
and you have to like
pull yourself out of it
to, like, be filming and
like, spreading your message?
- I would never, I would never film
if I wasn't in the right place.
I don't power through.
There's, I mean, you couldn't
wrap your head around
how much bad shit happens everyday to me,
and this company, and like,
that's actually the job.
My job is eating shit.
You know, like, everything's
on me, ultimately, right?
Yeah, I mean, I'm sure,
of course I get into funks, you know?
But, I have tremendous
perspective and like, my,
like, I have no sustained funk.
Like, even the thought of like,
a day, is out of question.
Like, a full day of being in a funk
is just not gonna happen.
It just can't.
Like, there's just nothing that can happen
that makes me change my mindset of like,
how good we have it, I mean ...
If you actually, all of you,
I don't know anything about
you enough to know this,
but just looking around the room,
the fact that you're sitting
in a building in New York City,
in America, and have an internship here,
you would probably shit your pants
if you, if there was a world ranking
on quality of life, happiness,
just net score of where
do you rank on earth?
Like, a new system came out,
it took everything into account,
it brain scanned you for
happiness, depression, all of it.
What is your net rank in the world?
You would be humbled by
how good your life is.
I don't think you have a perspective.
I don't think anybody does,
and I'm not even sure I do,
I just try my best to think about this,
kind of, almost daily.
Where do you rank out
of 7.7 billion people?
The answer, for a lot of
you, is outrageously high.
If you're a white dude in here
and your family has any
kind of financial security,
you're in outer space.
Outer fuckin' space.
That's humbling.
And then, for me, that's
kind of like the data,
but again, what isn't taken into account
at all in society, is like,
"Cool, you're a white dude
"With a family," like
to me, having too much
is the really, the other play.
Like, what we don't have is a read on
people's mental health, right?
And so, I know I have that too,
so now I'm just like, you know?
I can't get into a funk,
it's almost inappropriate, you know?
Not that I force it, it's
just become me, you know.
How many people work
out pretty religiously?
Think about when you didn't,
think about when you started,
and then, think about how it now feels
completely foreign not to.
That's what I do mentally.
Like, just fucking
contextualize your problem,
and let me give you a
really good piece of advice,
pay very close attention to
who's listening to you complain.
It's a very important tell.
Like, I would shit on you
if you complained to me.
So, pay close attention
because when it's your
mom, or it's another friend
that complains all the time,
you're in a bad system.
- [Intern] In terms of, like,
judgments and criticism,
where is the line of taking something
as constructive criticism, and
then, just on the other side,
being like, going with your
gut, and not listening to them?
- I'd like you to be a
hell of a lot more closer
to going with your gut
and not listening to them.
Especially, at this age.
At this age, you kind of
almost have to see it through
to see how right or wrong you are.
There's more upside in you figuring out
if you're right or wrong.
You can always take everybody's
feedback in your 30s.
You know?
Look, most people are just
gonna make assumptions,
just based on your age.
They're just giving you feedback
for the sake of feedback
'cause you're 20-something.
Now, if it's something like math,
then, it's black and white, and
you get to the wrong answer,
then, they were right
(laughs), like, you know?
But like, but like, the people
here in analytics and media,
like, that's like math,
and like, you could fuckin'
have any ego you want,
but if like it played out wrong, you lost,
which is what's great about it.
It's very, like, black and white,
but all the other stuff is very gray,
and becomes very subjective.
The great foundation of my
life is being undereducated.
It really worked for me,
just don't have that gear
of seeing the world the same way.
- Do you ever get stressed?
- I almost wonder if, like,
what ended up happening was,
you know, when you're a 22-year-old kid,
and you walk into a family business,
and you explode it,
and you're wanted now from there on at 23,
you're the foundation
of the financial success
of your entire family,
and you're the emotional
pillar of your family,
along with your mother,
so you're both financially
and emotionally responsible
for everything you love at 23,
you almost go into the other--
I almost feel like I've been
in stress in perpetuity,
that it's become happiness.
(laughter)
I don't know what else to say, you know?
I don't feel stressed.
I don't judge myself,
I feel like I'm trying.
I know what my intent is,
I feel like I'm trying really hard,
and like, my big thing is like,
before you say something to me,
like, why don't you look at yourself?
Like, it's really hard
for me to get going.
Like, man, would I love for
all of you to be empowered
with like, when your
parents say something,
to call them out on them
doing the same thing.
That's what parents do.
They impose their thing on you.
Your mom is doing what her mom did to her.
Even though, she hated
that her mom did it to her.
It's how humans work.
Anyway, probably ...
- But it just doesn't affect you?
- I'm a big fan, of like,
sleeping in the bed that you've made.
I got big ambitions, I'm trying
to be out here doin' shit?
Well, guess what?
No one should be crying for
me, and so, I can't complain.
I'm fucking, put myself out there, right?
Like, I'm putting myself out there,
I don't have to say yes to the interviews,
I don't have to fuckin'
be filming my fuckin' self
24 hours a day.
I made this bed, I gotta sleep in it,
everything that comes along with it,
and if I do something
fucking stupid or wrong,
and I get called out on it,
I need to own that shit,
and I'm okay with that 'cause
I don't think I'm perfect.
I'm just trying to stay narrow.
Narrow is my thing, you know?
Stay in my lane, you know?
That's why I don't talk, you
know, a lot of people are like,
"You don't talk about politics."
I'm like, "I wanna do homework on it,
"I don't wanna just shoot my opinion."
It's like, like, you know?
I've got opinions,
but like now, like, I just
think about all those things,
or about anything, anything.
I need to be thoughtful.
I stay very narrow, chess.
Two moves ...
I do so many things
that are actually setting
up something else,
but I get scrutinized, judged,
or viewed on the first move.
A jab isn't trying to knock
somebody out in a fight.
I'm really good at jabbing.
I'm really thoughtful,
I'm playing the long game.
- [Intern] So, I know you've
got an experience team,
and I've had some time
to look into like exit interview trends,
and I'd love to hear
from your perspective,
like, when you read
what someone had to say
about what it was like to
work here and work for you,
what's the best thing and the worst thing
that someone's ever said?
- I mean, in the most extremes,
it's like I'm devastated I'm leaving.
It's because of some
outrageous circumstance,
"like my parents are sick,
"or my significant other's
getting transferred,
"and like, this is
breaking my heart and soul.
"I wanna work here forever."
And in the other direction is,
this whole thing is full of shit,
you're full of shit, fuck you.
I've been undermined,
you're completely full of shit,
fuck you, fuck you, you're full of shit.
Those are the best and worst.
Yeah, it's super tough,
but what ends up
happening, back to stress,
or this and that, it's, I have empathy.
By the way, they might be right.
Like, I'm not crippled by the fact
that three people right
now could be terrible,
and like, serendipitously,
got teamed up, created
a triangle of terror,
and I haven't been able
to, like, weed it out yet.
The best part is though,
I don't want that.
Look, you were in the meeting
where I literally told the entire team,
like, from now on,
any time somebody's crying somewhere,
I need to know on the moment it happens.
You saw it, not for show for the inter--
You were in the meeting.
- [Intern] Yeah, I mean--
- That's who I am.
Like, so like, I sleep well at night.
Triangle of terror, and somebody
says I'm a piece of shit,
and this is all a facade.
I can live with that
because I understand that could be true.
Four offices, 900 people,
even though, I'm on the
pulse of every minute.
I'm trying out here, but like,
I'm not fuckin', you
know, like, omnipresent.
(laughter)
You know, and so, so ...
I just feel great with
my intent and my efforts.
I know I'm not making
financial decisions like 99.9.
Of course I am, 'cause
we have to make payroll,
but I'm not trying to
like, maximize profits,
so I can buy a helicopter
and feel good about myself,
and so, like, I just know I'm
way ahead of everything else,
and I read all that stuff,
I read everyone of those.
You know, I get them right away.
I fuckin' read, talk
about, I don't read shit.
I read every word, I try to synthesize it.
I email every one of them,
which is why we have
their non-Vayner email.
I try to, like, let them know
that I'm here for them in perpetuity.
If anybody ever works
at Vayner, for you guys,
just being an intern, if I
can help you in 19 years.
You email me, be like, "I was
an intern in fucking 2018,
"and da-da-da," and like, you know,
"now, my aunt wants to be--"
You know, I don't give a fuck.
Just feel free to reach out,
and so, intent trumps a lot.
You have to execute on your intent.
You know, a lot of my closest friends
kinda scrutinize, they're
like, "Intent, intent."
"you could intend to be a good guy,
"but shoot somebody with a gun, and then,"
I'm like, I get it,
but usually intent maps to
your actions, and so ...
- [Intern] Where do you
draw inspiration from?
When you started Vayner
and then also, how you make
your decisions correctly?
- I want legacy.
It's very insular, it's
not from somebody else.
You know, my inspiration is ...
I'm aware that something
really good happened
when I was produced, and
I wanna see it through.
I think I owe it to my
parents, I think I owe it to,
I'm just very driven by gratitude.
I'm very inspired by it.
I know good things happen,
mentally, really this, you know?
And I need to see it through.
You know, there's a curiosity
of how big can this be
that really fucks with me, in a good way.
Like, I really, really, really
think I'm gonna be Oprah.
(laughter)
Like for real,
which is amazing, like,
a singular individual
for a moment in time.
You know, it's really
interesting too, to me,
and I think about psycho, like
I analyze things, I'm like,
"If I'm right, and this
happens in nine years,
"it's gonna be an interesting time."
Like, in a world where, like, white dudes,
are like demonized, and
things of that nature,
like, is it important that--
Like, I think about the
fact that I'm penetrating
15-25 dudes and I'm pushing
empathy and kindness,
like, is this all meant to be?
You know, I get into
that, I definitely do.
I'm like, I'm such an alpha male,
yet, like, what I preach
is so traditionally soft,
and like, I get to live my life.
Like, I get to be like, in an airport,
and see a hood dude roll
up to me and be like,
"Yo, gratitude, dawg."
(laughter)
You know, it's like, it's fun.
It's like, I'm seeing the piece,
I'm seeing the puzzle come together
while being unbelievable comfortable
in my capitalistic, you know, ambition.
You know, I think I'm a very funny read,
even as I read myself.
It's like, I've got all
this underlying stuff,
but the thing that most
people know is like,
"He wants to buy the jets,"
which is very like douchey, and like,
the whole thing's super interesting to me,
and I'm always like, "Am
I sandbagging everybody?
"Like, is that what I put out?
"Like, is that why I speak that way?
"Like, why is it that they like me more
"as they get closer, not further?"
Like, it's all very interesting to me.
I see my patterns, it's
the underdog thing.
You know, like, why will I turn on,
like a golf match, give a fuck,
but like whoever's the
underdog, that's who I'm for.
Like, fuckin' MAC Conference
college basketball game at
night, turn on underdog, right?
Like, Kobe, hate him.
Last season, washed up, love him.
Like, I'm very like, am
I doing that to myself?
Like, do I like the fact that
everybody in the ad world,
like Ad Age never covers
us, they covered us today
about fuckin', I'm bartering for snacks.
That's a dig, that's a razz,
but like, I love that, like I need that.
I'm driven by being underestimated,
and then I think, "Oh shit, I
must be sandbagging myself."
My team gets so mad at me, they're like,
"Why don't you talk about being smart?"
You know, like, I talk about working hard.
My propaganda is like my
selfie at four in the morning
looking like shit, on
the way to the airport.
It's not my thoughtfulness of like,
20 years of being right
about a ton of shit.
So, I don't know,
like it's fun to analyze
myself for myself,
but I try not to do it too much
because I'm always worried of like
becoming a caricature of myself,
which I think is a very dangerous move,
and so, that's why I rely
so much on intuition,
'cause I don't even wanna
allow myself to think too much,
because I don't wanna, right?
I speak my truth, you saw that day,
with like the MLB, like I
will always speak my truth,
and I'll curse, and I'll dress down,
and I'll let the world come to me, got it?
The world came to me.
When I was your age, this,
everything I've done was unacceptable.
Bad at school, casual, dress for respect,
cursing at scale and in public.
All unacceptable.
Still kind of weirdly unacceptable,
but a lot less than it was.
- [Intern] How does ego tie into success?
- It doesn't, it's the
great vulnerability.
Ego is just a dress for insecurity.
Ego is very different than confidence.
Ego is the manifestation of insecurity.
I'm very confident, but
not blindly, you know?
And I also, like, I said something once,
somebody tweeted about it this weekend,
and it really is my biggest truth,
I genuinely think I'm going
to be all-time special.
Like, I live my life as in like,
"What kind of statues
are they gonna put up?"
I'm being dead fucking serious.
At the same token,
I equally believe, like, the day I die,
it could be a nonevent, or I'll
get like 24 hours on social,
and people will tell their
stories of what I did for them,
and then, it's over.
So having this hardcore
push and pull of like,
being all time and
insignificant at the same time,
is a balance that's super important,
and I don't think ego
allows you to do that.
Ego is, I'm insecure,
let me peacock and make
pretend, it's bullying.
I fucking hate it.
- [Intern] What has working
with Ryan and Mary Kate given you?
Like, what have they opened your eyes to?
- Well first, it's given
me like, enormous ambition
for the kind of companies I wanna buy
because their working
relationship is tremendous,
like, just kindness, and cute, and nice,
and perfect, real good.
I haven't spent a lot of time
really digging in, like,
the publishing world,
I had a sense for it,
it's not that lateral.
To me, it's just ...
Watching a good, kindness leadership team.
Ryan is, I would argue,
is a byproduct of how I
think about the world.
Like, my ambition is that
more CEOs are like Ryan,
caring, but alpha, and all that,
but nothing stands out.
I haven't spent that much
time with them either, and ...
That's just the truth.
There's nothing, you know,
I don't wanna say nothing
because I don't want them
to have their feelings hurt,
but it's pretty close to nothing so far.
- Thanks.
- Obviously, all of us are
very invested in social media.
These days it's like the biggest thing,
and I feel like a lot of what you say
is not letting other people's
opinions affect you too much,
and I know, I'm sure in
your comment section,
it blows back all the time,
both positive and negative,
so, does that ever, you
know, get to you in a way?
And I know sometimes you do respond.
So, what's the, the mindset there?
- Why do I respond?
- Yeah.
To people who have negative things--
- Serendipity, like I'm in a mood.
You know, like, just like, I just,
truthfully, I think it's funny.
I think it's funny,
I just think it's funny to like pick some,
first of all, what I love that I do is
a lot of people razz on people,
but they'll like dark out their account.
Like, I just, I'm like,
"Look, if you're publicly saying this
"I'm gonna publicly put you on blast."
I think that's funny.
(laughter)
Not much, like, like, I'm
listen, here's where I'm at.
Who the fuck has time to
watch 87 hours of my content
to have a better feel
of who I actually am,
so that they're grounded
in a good opinion?
And I know what I'm putting out there.
Like, if you just see one
fucking video on Instagram,
and I'm acting confident and peacocking
because I'm pissed about
somebody who's being a bully,
but it looks like I'm being a bully
'cause I'm cursing and
being alpha, like that's it.
It's all you need.
Like, if you were
brought up in a household
where cursing was bad, you don't like me.
If you like, first of all,
everybody in the advertising industry
that's living in the old world,
by default has to be worried
about me and doesn't like me.
Like, I have empathy to why somebody,
or ultimately why people, guys,
think about the makeup, the mental makeup
of somebody who takes
time out of their life
to leave a negative comment
about somebody else.
Do you know how sad I feel for them?
In the history of my life,
to the day I go in the grave,
I would never do that.
Why?
It's a complete waste of time.
I'm in a place where I
need to comment negatively
and try to tear somebody
down with my three minutes,
first of all, you have
to consume the content
to get a thought.
Second, you have to,
like, have that in you
that you think that's a good idea.
Do you know how much pain you're in
when you leave the negative comment?
Do you know how fucked up you are, macro?
I'm never worried about anybody
who's dragging people down.
They're weak as fuck,
and most people think they're strong
'cause they're loud and mean.
They're so weak.
- You started when you were fourteen.
You kept going, you've worked
really hard, obviously,
but you didn't go to school.
You did shitty when you
were in high school,
you, all this stuff.
You don't like reading,
you don't like writing.
How do you prove merit,
not, you personally,
and how when you were younger,
how would we prove our merit?
- You don't.
Dude, I got shit on like shit, you don't.
Merit only gets proven on the field.
Like, if you spent as much time
thinking about how to gain respect
into putting all that energy
into actually executing
to get the respect,
you'd be in a totally different place.
I didn't, I just took my punches.
Dude, the level of
judgment I had at your age.
I was going to Mt. Ida College,
which literally went out
of business this year.
(laughter)
I went to Mt. Ida College,
which nobody had ever heard
of, and still haven't.
I worked at my dad's liquor
store at this point in my life.
Getting into any argument
that I'm gonna be good or,
it just didn't even cross my mind.
I just worked and got better at my craft.
You're spending to much time justifying,
instead of executing.
You're having arguments
with yourself first,
then your parents, then
the people closest to you.
Don't, just go do.
You're literally debating
the outcome of a game
in the national anthem part.
You're just ...
You're just, you're valuing
other people's opinions.
Don't.
You have to earn it.
You haven't earned shit yet.
I get, you could be a prospect.
A lot of first picks overall fuckin' suck.
So, I don't, you know, way too much,
like a social commentary,
and fuckin' pontificating
about something that hasn't
happened yet, and like,
listening to someone else's
playbook is ridiculous.
Especially, somebody who
played it 25 or 35 years ago.
Your parents' opinion is stunningly bad.
They're awesome, like I know,
or maybe they're terrible, I don't know,
but nonetheless, it's
completely not practical.
They're utterly incapable of projecting
the context of the playing
field that you're playing in.
And like, the biggest fear I have
is that half of you are
going to pander to it
because they're going
to financially subsidize
your opening act.
You're pandering to it
because you want a better
apartment out the gate,
and so, parents are going to pay for it,
thus you feel a subconscious need
to appease them in the short term.
See, this is not just the parents' game.
That's what's fun to think.
This is fucking you.
There's a really great way,
to like, eliminate your parents' leverage.
Get off their payroll.
- Did you ever go through a time
where you disagreed with your parents?
- I don't agree with my parents
about anything or everything.
I never even fucking value
their opinion enough.
I got off their payroll, and
fucking put them on my payroll.
(laughter)
You know?
And not really, 'cause, you
know, it's a little douchey,
but like, I came in the game,
and fuckin', right away,
contributed and paid them back
for everything they've ever done for me.
It was just never in that place.
The big, you know, it's
real fun in here, like haha,
and everybody who's gonna watch,
they'll be like shitting on your parents,
until you realize, you're
fuckin' full of shit.
You should have no respect
until you actually execute it.
You could have reading,
again, back to sports,
you can have a reputation,
but like, first of all,
your entire academic career is horseshit
compared to what you're about to go into.
I could give a fuck about
what you've done in school.
It's got zero mapping
to the reality of what you're about to do.
So, that's one, and then, two,
get off their payroll, fake environments,
and they want you on their
payroll, if they can afford it,
'cause then, they have control.
Then, you can do the things
that makes them feel good
to say to their friends.
You wanna be happy, get
off your parents' payroll.
It's much more fun to take the subway
and have three shitty roommates
than to be psychologically
controlled by your parents.
Fuck, I like that, Caleb.
That's the clip right there.
(laughter)
No really, like, that's the first time
I've said it that way, that
really makes sense to me.
That's the biggest issue right
now, everyone's posturing.
- [Intern] What did you do to
gain emotional intelligence
and self-awareness?
- I don't know, man, like my
mom has it, so I took her DNA.
She gave it to me, so that's good.
You know, I think,
I think adversity is the
foundation of success,
and I think my whole
childhood had adversity.
I didn't speak the language,
I wasn't physically a menace.
I was, you know, I was terrible at school.
Like, I feel like by the time
I kinda like hit the game,
it was all upside.
Like, the reason I couldn't
hear anybody anymore
was 'cause what they were
saying wasn't super interesting.
So, I said fuck it, I'll just,
but even, you know what's funny,
I'm painting a false picture.
It never bothered me. I do
think there was a little bit
of a natural emotional
intelligence foundation there,
but I will say, practice.
Like, I do believe in that,
I definitely have evolved.
I'm struggling to deconstruct it,
which is why I don't talk about it a lot,
but like, I do think I've
said one or two things here
that maybe helped one or two of you,
but I think if you literally repeated,
like, living in a shitty apartment
with three people I hate,
and taking the subway
is better than being emotionally
controlled by my parents
may make you not take unlimited Uber
from your parents when
you get out of school.
No, thank you.
I don't know, I think that's cool.
Accountability is really attractive.
- [Intern] How would you say you balance,
like, your work/family life?
- Intuitively and specifically,
meaning I don't judge myself.
So like, if I miss my daughter's recital
because Kraft wants to
give us 10 million dollars,
I'm gonna miss it, and
I don't give a fuck.
Meaning, I don't give a
fuck of people judging me
on what the current state
of proper politically correct parenting is
because like, I don't know, I
love my dad with all my heart,
and I didn't see him the
first 15 years of my life.
There's a million ways to do it,
and I, my intent is there.
I always try to make everything, you know?
But then, purposefully,
like I'm really excited
that I'm taking these three
weeks off in August every year.
It worked, like the world checks out
these kind of two weeks,
three weeks in August,
and in Christmas, and I'm hacking,
and I'm always thinking about new things,
and just trying to find new
ways to spend more time,
and you know, felt like I was winning,
and then, felt I needed
a little extra boost.
So, I started doing,
like, half-day Friday.
Not half-day, but like, half-day,
six, getting home at 6pm on
Friday (laughs) my half-day.
Just trying, you know.
Trying to communicate with
(inaudible) more, and more,
which is something we've
gotten a little bit better at
in the last half year.
Effort.
Here's what happens, if you
listen to this whole talk,
when you actually don't
value anybody else's opinion
but your own, then you
just spend all you time
on trying to make the things
you believe in better.
- [Intern] The reason that
I wanted to intern at VaynerMedia
is because I see it as, like, a pioneer
in the advertising industry,
and I'm like, all for advertising,
that's what I'm passionate about.
- That's awesome.
- [Intern] So, how long do
you think it's gonna take
for the industry to evolve
to where it needs to get us?
- My intuition is, it
will really gain momentum
when the economy collapses.
There's no reason for them to do it now.
Vayner's model is, is just not accepted,
thus, doesn't allow for us to
get all the dollars we get,
but I think people are starting
to realize we're too big
for it to not have merit,
and I definitely think I'm inspiring
the next generation to
build their own shops
that look more like it.
So, I think in a decade,
there'll be a lot more
acceptance to what we're doing.
Let's see how we're, how
are we doing on time?
Five minutes ago, 15 minutes ago.
This is fun.
One last question.
- I know you said that--
- If you don't care
about anybody's opinion,
that's the last question, it
becomes much easier to ask.
(laughter)
- Well, I know you said
that you didn't really
learn much from school, but you were like,
always really hard working,
I still have two more
years of school left,
even though, like, being
here, I've learned to like,
I think, how to be a better person,
like, working hard, like
I've gained ambition,
but, do you have any advice on like
what I should work on in school?
Like, I mean, hard skills
that you would value?
While I'm there?
- I think that's a great question
for a lot of other people.
That just doesn't come natural to me.
Like, what?
Like, every piece of information's
literally on your phone,
and then, like, learning process.
Every organization has its own process.
You'll learn more in the first week,
of wherever the fuck you go,
then you will, like ...
Listen, I'm not trying to shit on school.
Like, especially, 'cause
I think people, like, look
if you guys wanna work
at Boston Consulting
in this building, you better
fucking get your grades up,
go to grad school, go to
fucking Stanford or Harvard,
that's how you get into McKinsey, right?
If you wanna be a doctor, like,
you need to learn the craft,
but like, for most of us,
if, I mean, my biggest piece of advice,
is to meet as many people
and make significant
relationships, like friends,
like, for real, and
enjoy the last vacation
that looks like this in your life.
It's a fucking vacation.
Like, I would enjoy it.
Like, so many of you are gonna stress out
your last two years thinking
it's gonna be an indicator
to your life.
Just don't fail out.
That's my rally cry, just don't fail,
like, if you really think in 2018,
that your grade-point average
swaying of one or two points,
let alone point something,
have any indication
on how your life is gonna
play out, you're fuckin' lost.
Like, skip a class, and like
go, like, listen to a reading
by somebody at the Barnes & Noble,
(laughter)
while they're still open
an hour away, you know?
Yeah, just don't fail out.
Like, help me, educate me.
Like, what are you learning in
class that you think is real?
- I feel like my learning is so outdated.
Especially, like even
week one, like you said,
like all my media professors,
and like, if like that
applies, like 10, 20 years ago,
it's like, not current.
- They made me memorize a graph.
(laughter)
- I like, I like the people
experience of college.
- Of course, it's fun as fuck.
- Yeah, I like being with people
that are my age.
- Of course!
- People that understand--
- Me too, but guess what
else you can do with 40,000.
You could go to every single
fucking music festival on Earth.
(laughter)
Like, like this whole
notion of propaganda,
of like, but it's the people, sure,
why don't you give me
back the fucking 40K,
and why don't I fucking
go to Coachella and Ibiza,
and to fucking Austral--
Like, you could hang out with
kids your age in perpetuity.
That fucking, that last fucking frontier
that college is fucking trying
to sell everybody on, like,
but you grow up, and you
get to be with your people,
and you meet lifelong friends.
Like, give me 40K, I'll fuckin'
make it way better for you.
You know how much more
fun it is to go to like,
the Dominican Republic, 4,000 people deep
for 3,000 bucks for a week?
You can do so, like, they're
gonna lose that game.
Somebody, like, I may do it myself.
Some entrepreneur, she or
he is gonna come along,
and start a company
and be like, yeah cool.
Let me , let me set this up, or like,
WeWork and some of these
coworking spaces are doing,
they're just setting up,
like the campus replication is super easy,
and a hell of a lot more,
like you could learn a lot more.
Like, let me send all of you,
like 150 deep to Pari, to
France to work a harvest
in the vineyards, and
like every three days,
go into Paris and just like, fuck.
I'm with you, I agree,
but that is the last reason
that college should stay up
and be able to do the
bullshit they're doing,
and right now, it's the
leading fucking ROI.
You can play Fortnite together
(laughter)
somewhere else.
Like, give me 40K each,
and I'll fucking have you
playing with Ninja every night.
It's so fucked, bro,
but that being said, I'm on
an ideological execution now.
You're in it, you're not going anywhere.
So, to that point, make
it more than seven people
that are your friends.
To your point, everyone's
like, "I love that."
I'm like, "You have nine friends."
Like, you really wanna
take advantage of like,
"Oh, it's awesome campus life.
"Like culture, we can go," (claps)
"Like serendipity," like
then, do something about it.
Instead of what everyone's doing
which is in your fucking clique of six.
Like, really fuckin' break that.
Like, that was always the
best thing that I had.
I had like nine different friend groups
that like, made no sense,
that like, never let
me get popular enough,
and like, was very weird, and like,
people were so confused by me.
Best thing I did.
- [Intern] Since we're, like,
people everywhere are
spending like $200,000
for four years of college,
do you think--
- How many of you are
collecting debt for college?
Tell the truth, it's okay, just curious.
That to me is like the thing
that I'm spending my whole
life trying to figure out.
Go ahead.
- [Intern] Do you think it's
gonna like die out or change?
- Yeah, college is new.
Guys, college is fucking new.
In 1940, which is five minutes ago,
not everybody's fucking
dream was to go to college.
- [Intern] What do you
think is gonna happen?
- I don't know, but I know
it's in trouble, you know?
Like, this conversation was
not happening 10 years ago.
When the economy collapses
on the back of all the college debt
that all of you are occurring,
and everybody blames the
racket of college for it,
it'll be like banks, other things,
the brand will be so bad,
the conversation will change,
and I do believe that you will
be the generation of parents
that don't force your
kids to go to college.
So I think, 30.
I think, Stanford, Harvard,
I think the top 17 will be able to hold on
a little bit longer just on brand,
but I think really good
schools, like the state schools,
like kinda that upper middle,
I think they're very vulnerable.
Michigan's an amazingly good school,
but collecting 200,000 in
debt with that interest rate
for a good, solid Michigan degree
in the real life, the day after ...
No way.
Yeah?
- Do you have time for one more?
- Mhmm.
- So, you talked about, like
you've kinda blocking out
opinions, and like, you don't really like,
you respect them, but you
kinda like, put it to the side,
disregard it, like--
- I try to, I try to filter
it and, first of all,
pay attention to who's
giving you the advice.
What's they're KPI, like
why are they doing it?
Go ahead.
- I guess, that kind of like addresses it,
but I was gonna say like,
doesn't that kind of let your
ego take, like, the wheel?
And, kinda like, where's
like the humility,
and like, how do you
self-reflect, like say,
"Maybe they're right, maybe
like, I could improve."
- You'll love this, I
don't think I'm right.
He gives me his opinion,
I do something else,
I don't necessarily think I'm right,
I just would rather die on my own sword.
Right?
Like, that makes sense, right?
Like, I don't know, like, actually,
I think it's enormous humility.
It's because, I don't
value my own opinion,
why would I value yours,
but I'm gonna do what I wanna do
because if it's wrong, it's
much more fun to blame myself
than to blame you.
Guys, when it ends up being wrong,
you're gonna blame your parents,
and then, that gets really ugly.
So, I think it's about
accountability and humility.
I don't value your opinion
'cause I don't value mine.
I'm gonna do me, and
when I lose, I'm like,
"You're a fucking idiot,"
and when it works, I'm like, "Yeah!"
Make sense?
- Yeah, thank you.
- Right, that's where it comes down to.
I think it's actually the rever--
You know, it's all these
things are the reverse.
You know, it looks like ego,
it's actually massive humility.
I don't even value my own.
So, you're valuing yours,
but then you're valuing someone else's,
I don't value either, then just go,
and then, like deal
with it after the fact.
Then, when you know your
intent's good, like,
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
Like, happy is not about money
or awards or recognition.
It's about just knowing yourself.
Guys, I'm cool, if you thought that
I thought the apex of my
coolness was gonna be at 42,
you've got another thing coming.
Like, there was no indication
that entrepreneurship
was gonna be cool.
There was no fucking scenario
that I thought (inaudible)
would be DMing me yesterday.
That doesn't, that doesn't play out
in the way that I saw a
business man playing out.
I just stayed fuckin' true the whole time,
and then, it fuckin' worked out.
I really believe in that shit.
Listen to yourself,
please, listen to yourself.
YouTube, leave a comment below.
I'm dying, dying for your insight
on what you just saw.
What stood out, give me some time stamps.
What stood out?